ووهان الصين ،
حيث تم الإبلاغ عن أول حالات معروفة لـ Coven
19 في ديسمبر 2019.
في شهر مارس ، أصدرت منظمة الصحة العالمية
تقريرًا من 120 صفحة
يحدد أربع نظريات حول أصله ، وهو
سيناريو محتمل للغاية ينتشر فيه الفيروس إلى
البشر من خلال حيوان مثل الخفافيش أو
البنغول.
من غير المحتمل للغاية حدوث تسرب معمل ،
لكننا الآن نحصل على معلومات جديدة
حول الباحثين في أحد مختبرات الصين ،
ومعهد ووهان لعلم الفيروسات ، قال شخصان تم
إطلاعهما على تقرير استخباراتي
أمريكي إن التقرير وجد ثلاثة
باحثين من المختبر
أصيبوا بالمرض في نوفمبر 2019 واضطروا إلى ذلك
أدخل إلى المستشفى ، ورد
في صحيفة وقائع وزارة الخارجية من
يناير / كانون الثاني
فقط أنه كان هناك العديد من الباحثين في
خريف 2019
مع أعراض تتفق مع كل من
covid19
والأمراض الموسمية الشائعة ، استجاب
مدير مختبر ووهان الوطني للسلامة البيولوجية
قائلاً لوسائل الإعلام الحكومية العالمية أن
التقرير يقتبس كذبة كاملة
واقتباس  هذه الادعاءات لا أساس لها من الصحة
هذه المعلومات الجديدة
تضيف إلى القلق المتزايد بشأن الحاجة
إلى  تحقيق أكثر
تعمقًا في المكان الذي بدأ فيه كوفيد 19
بالإشارة إلى نقص الشفافية في
عملية من ،
أعتقد أنه يجب علينا مواصلة
التحقيق في
ما حدث في الصين حتى
نكتشف قدر استطاعتنا
ما حدث بالضبط أنا بريت  كونواي
التقارير